204 mille cadres de contamination
confirmés actuellement en france et le
taux d'incidence du virus nombre de
nouveaux cas pour 100000 habitants ne
cessent d'augmenter
l'indicateur située à 4,4 peu avant la
mi juillet a atteint 16,7 la semaine
dernière et a franchi la barre des 50 à
paris des chiffres qui inquiète le
gouvernement
si nous ne réagissons pas collectivement
nous nous exposons un risque élevé de
reprise épidémique qui sera difficile à
contrôler elle mettra à nouveau sous
tension l'ensemble de la chaîne de santé
de la médecine de ville aux services
hospitaliers
elle mettra aussi sous tension notre
économie notre système éducatif
notre vie collective et culturels la
situation liée à l'épidémie de kovy 19
s'est dégradée au cours des derniers
jours tout pour éviter un autre
confinement dix huit départements sont
actuellement placés en vigilance modérée
3 en vigilance est levée jean castex a
appelé les préfets à étendre le plus
possible les obligations du port du
masque en extérieur une mesure mise en
place depuis lundi dans les rues les
plus fréquentées de la capitale
il ya quand même pas mal de gens qu'on
parle masque du tout sur eux là on voit
beaucoup de gens qui passent après je
sais pas si tout le monde est au courant
moi je pense que oui faut faire
attention mais là paris évident en ce
moment quand même mais si c'était au
mois de septembre je pense que c'est
quand même
asus yeux de m faut faire attention
c'est contraignant mais en fait bon là
ça va s qui les taux mais la rue des
martyrs et puis je sais que montmartre
aussi ils font ça il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de monde et en vrai si on va
éviter une deuxième vague en plus à
paris enfin tout sauf confinement
renforcer la vigilance tandis que le
nombre d'entrées en réanimation augmente
lui aussi rapidement
le gouvernement a annoncé un
durcissement des mesures et du contrôle
de leur application
les événements de plus de 5000 personnes
restent interdits jusqu'au 30 octobre
quant à emmanuel macron il a rappelé je
cite que l'épidémie ne prenait pas de
vacances